china la verdad es que se molesta por
una visita que está enmarcada no en ir
directamente a taiwán sino en una visita
en todo hacia donde me los iba a visitar
una gran cantidad de aliados de eeuu y a
muchas democracias y sistemas que son
mucho más republicanos chic chinas en
general en esta última etapa lo que ha
hecho es que ha exacerbado
sus anuncios pero fundamentalmente ha
sobreactuado las situaciones que uno ve
que se plasman a la interna y a la
externa y ya lo vemos o lo hemos visto
en lo que fue el bloqueo total al puerto
de shanghai con un solo anuncio de
omicron en un país ellos cierran un
puerto totalmente acá de nuevo tenemos
una sobreactuación muy importante de
china hacia una visita que no parecería
tan importante y como entender la
advertencia de china de que no se
quedarán quietos con la visita y de que
washington está jugando con fuego
indudablemente los países que tienen
baja institucionalidad y en definitiva
no tienen unas democracias y situaciones
que los pueden de alguna forma darle
mayor garantías y seguridades que tienen
tienden a dar este tipo de anuncios
hoy hoy por hoy la presidenta del
congreso lo que está haciendo es visitar
otra democracia no olvidemos que taiwán
es una democracia real con su forma
republicana y con su parlamento
establecido en la presidenta de taiwán
es una presidenta por voto libre y en
general hoy lo que está haciendo pero si
es una visita formal a lo que serían sus
sus países o en este caso democracias
amigas usted previamente dijo que china
básicamente está sobreactuando y que la
visita no tiene mucha importancia si es
así porque le interesa al congreso de
eeuu reiterar el apoyo a taiwán con esta
eventual visita de pelosi y si es
realmente o no necesario el viaje
eeuu ha tenido una política un tanto
extraña para con taiwán de los últimos
años hacia acá ella eeuu reconoce una
única china que es china continental o
sea china pekín dándole a taiwán otro
rango de reconocimiento naturalmente de
comercio totalmente con taiwán y en
especial armas etcétera etcétera y
además tiene un acuerdo una ley por así
decir que se plasma en el congreso de
protección a la no invasión de china
pekín hacia taiwán
en definitiva
es importante
taiwán hoy para eeuu creo que es
importante visitar a cada uno de sus
socios en asia es importante de alguna
forma también que el mundo libre tenga
su propia óptica y su propia forma de
poder compensarse y tener sus gestiones
no siempre hay que ceder a las presiones
de otros sistemas que en definitiva no
están acostumbrados a que se les
contradiga o que haya oposiciones a sus
propias ideas